The apocalypse is here, ladies and gentlemen, and so is
my breakdown of "American Horror Story: Apocalypse".
Sorry it's taken a few days to get this out,
but I was busy finishing
my "Castle Rock Explained" series.
But enough about that.
We're here for the end of the world, so let's get into it.
Socialite Coco St. Pierre Vanderbilt is getting
her hair done by famous hairstylist, Mr. Gallant,
or as the French say, "Gall-oh".
In fact, she even says
he could be the next Chris McMillan,
which, for those of you who aren't on the Rodeo Drive socialite scene, is a famous real-life Hollywood stylist.
Also, huge points for the makeup artist
who even put glitter on Evan Peters' fingernails.
Mallory, played here by
Billie Lourd, Carrie Fisher's daughter,
is Coco's assistant who really wants Coco to have her finely pressed juice because they're so in right now.
But then something even
worse than a bad haircut happens:
A ballistic missile is inbound for L.A.
Coco's billionaire father calls and
informs her he has four spots reserved for the family
in the event of a nuclear fallout.
But because he's in Hong Kong,
he and the fam won't make it.
The signal goes out after what can only be
assumed is a nuclear bomb hitting the city.
Coco's boyfriend, played here by
"Billy on the Street", is at work,
busy preparing a six-part limited series of "Free Willy".
Numerous international strikes have been confirmed
and Coco tells him to meet her at the airport.
Mr. Gallant comes to get his Nana Evie,
a widow of a former MGM studio owner.
She tells him it's all fake news,
"You are fake news."
and that she'll bring the burnt champagne,
which for you non-millionaire
widows of major Hollywood studios means
a bottle of champagne that was frozen
at one point and lost some of its prestige.
Kind of like Nana Evie herself.
Coco says she'll give Mallory her brother's tickets and she needs her assistant. She's helpless without her.
And Mallory completely
ditches her family and agrees to go.
These dudes have apparently decided
it's a great time to steal some fruit,
before somebody's body comes crashing onto the car.
Team Coco arrives at the airport,
and I love how these dudes
are casually just doing their jobs,
even though the world is ending. That's commitment.
The driver here has some sweet "Mad Max"
gloves, and I gotta say, he's pretty badass.
Mr. Gallant rolls up with
Nana Evie and begs her to let them on.
After all, who's gonna do her hair when the world ends?
The airport workers then decide
to turn on them, coming for the plane.
Jason Statham over here fights them off as Coco releases Brock from his monogamy arrangement
and they escape from the ravaging horde.
And can we all just have a moment of silence
for this woman who tried to steal some meat?
Brock sees Coco's plane fly overhead as
he leaves her with some parting words of love -
"YOU BITCH!"
I wouldn't be surprised if we see this
character make a return later on in the series.
In the plane, Mallory checks to see where they're going, but the pilots are gone - and even worse, the stewardess.
A bomb blast goes off, and for a brief moment,
you can see the plane automatically adjust,
suggesting it's an automatic plane
or mysterious force controlling it.
Flashback 40 minutes before the bomb,
and we're introduced to Timmy,
who's eagerly awaiting his results from UCLA.
And he gets in! Way to go, Timmy!
And did you catch "American Horror Story"
Easter egg of Pepper being one of the male recipients?
Then dad comes in, being a total
buzzkill, explaining it's World War III.
But before they can think of a plan,
two agents from the Cooperative storm in,
explaining that Timothy has been selected to
survive because of his exceptional genetic makeup.
This video has been sponsored by AncestryDNA.
He refuses to go when he's forcefully taken by
super soldiers and locked in an underground bunker.
There, he meets Emily, before the bomb goes off.
Apparently, his super genetics
make him susceptible to crying.
Two weeks later, they're taken to Outpost 3,
one of ten around the world,
built in minimal fallout zones.
Which is a bit odd, since if they
were built in minimal fallout zones,
they would a) either have known
where the bombs were to hit beforehand,
or b) built them really, really fast.
Which we'll find out later they didn't.
Timmy and Emily are given hazmat suits and dropped off before being greeted by the welcoming committee.
Kylo Ren leads them across a field where
they see two people dressed in Amish clothing,
pleading that they won't do it again before being shot.
The masks these guys wear are eerily similar to the plague doctor masks from medieval times.
The extended noses were used to
stuff herbes and spices to ward off miasma,
the belief that disease was spread through the air.
Down in the bunker, they're decontaminated,
and we catch a brief glimpse
of Kathy Bates's character Mead,
who we'll later learn is the
head of security for the bunker.
Sarah Paulson arrives, playing Wilhelmina
Venable, and welcomes them to Outpost 3.
Her last name sounding a lot like venerable,
which is a common epithet used in Christian theology
to denote someone who should be given respect
based on their age, character or wisdom.
She says the bomb was a cleansing fire
and that this is a new beginning.
The Cooperative, the organization
in charge of putting this all together,
is a collection of the dozen
greatest minds mankind has to offer.
The twelve are known as "the Visionaries",
and my guess is we'll get to
meet some of them later on.
There aren't any generators down here,
but there is some form of electricity,
considering the keycard used to get in and the elevator.
Timmy and Emily are told they're
"Purples" and assigned their own suites.
Purples are elite, the worthy, chosen to survive.
Unlike the Greys, who are the worker ants.
And the Outpost itself is even designed like
an anthill with multiple winding pathways.
Emily asks what Wilhelmina's role
is in all of this, to which she responds
She's the strong right arm of the
Cooperative, and down here, there are rules.
They aren't allowed to leave due to
the risk of "canker puss monsters".
And worst of all, no unauthorised copulation of any kind,
which was what these two were apparently doing.
Timmy takes a shower when
he sees "666" in the condensation.
A voice whispers, "Beware, Timothy".
Now, this is a huge loose thread, because we don't
come back to either of these by the end of the episode.
In time for cocktails, it looks like
they're wearing attire from the 1800s South,
which leads me to believe
they're somewhere in Louisiana,
which would tie into season three's "Coven".
Mr. Gallant complains about the
same song being played every night,
"Calling Occupants of Interplanetary Craft"
by The Carpenters,
a song about telepathy
and reaching out to other worlds.
Mallory has been relegated to a Grey
and pleads to Coco for her to go
to Venable and make her a Purple.
Venable rings a bell, indicating
their delicious cube dinners are ready.
Each cube containing every vitamin
they need, and Coco ain't havin' it.
She wants real food, like "Pirate's Booty".
Venable puts her in her place
and explains the gravity of the situation:
They only have 18 months of nutrition stocked,
and if they want to survive, they need to ration carefully.
Not to mention there's been a
perimeter alert. Something penetrated the ground.
A carrier pigeon with a message from their benefactors:
Three out of the ten Outposts have been overrun.
They're the last of humanity,
the last vestiges of civilized life.
Mead is informed by Mrs. Lurch that there's a
spike in contamination coming from the room.
Someone has broken the clean rule.
The Geiger counter, a machine used to detect
radiation, identifies the culprits: Mr. Gallant and Stu.
They're sent to the decontamination showers,
where Stu is shot because his levels are too high.
At night, Ms. Venable and Mead hold a secret meeting,
where they break their
own rules by wearing purple outfits.
Venable says they're the only ones
that matter, and we learn Stu was set up:
Mead put the counter to a higher sensitivity.
This was either to keep them
in control or to thin the herd.
They play an old 1940's Whitman set of Old Maid,
a Victorian card game for two or more players,
probably deriving from an ancient gambling game
in which the loser pays for the drinks.
The drinks here being mineral water.
They both relish the pain they caused their captives,
and how they're undermining the
Cooperative by making up their own rules.
Venable says there is no Cooperative, it's only them.
Which doesn't necessarily mean
the Cooperative doesn't exist,
it just means they've gone rogue.
The others are still getting over
the death of Stu when Venable arrives.
As a consolation, she's prepared a
Bonne Bouche, a French word for "treat".
Another hint this could be taking place in the South.
Apparently, they have "resources" for special occasions.
Venable uses this occasion to stress how
it's important to follow the rules for everyone's safety.
Gallant takes out what looks like a tooth before everyone realizes that the stew they're eating is, well, Stu.
"The stew is Stu!"
The group argues whether
or not the food was actually Stu,
when the radio changes to
Maureen McGovern's "Morning After",
believing the Cooperative is saying,
"Hang on, we're coming for you."
That is until 18 months pass, and if you
recall, that's how long their supplies would last.
No one has come and nuclear winter has taken over.
Timmy and Emily are together, stating that
even in all this death, something was born,
which could mean they broke a rule and a
baby's on the way, or simply that their love was born.
Venable cuts back supplies, stating they'll
need to go to half a cube a day if they want to survive.
Mutiny kicks in with Mallory stating,
"I say we take our chances outside".
Since when do they let a Grey talk?
Mr. Gallant is about to be put in his place by Ms. Lurch,
when the alarm goes off, indicating a perimeter breach.
A horse-drawn carriage arrives, with a
member of the Cooperative, Michael Langdon.
And you know this guy means business
because his badge says "unlimited clearance".
But look here at the signature for
"President of the Cooperative".
It looks eerily like the word "Lucifer",
and his ID number ends in 666.
The same number found in Timmy's
shower and the number of the Devil.
Inside, we get our first look of Michael Langdon,
who looks like he just came off
the set of "Interview with a Vampire",
which, coincidentally enough, is also partly set in Louisiana.
Mead kills one of the horses because it's contaminated,
and we get our first brief glimpse
of what could be the puss monsters,
taking its corpse into the woods to be eaten.
Back in the bunker, Langdon tells Venable
that three more Outposts have been overrun
and three won't make it until the end of the year,
leaving their Outpost as the only one left,
but he's here to change that.
There's another facility, an impregnable
sanctuary with enough food for a decade,
but it's reserved only for those worthy of survival.
He's here to weed out the worthy, which
could mean next episode could be a bloodbath.
I hope you'll stay tuned with me for more
AHS breakdowns, and remember until next time:
Daddy loves you very much.